attention on the North largely focuses
on climate change and Arctic sovereignty
but for the predominantly aboriginal
population of the Arctic the health
crisis is shaping up to be the most
urgent issue on the agenda in native
lands infants are more likely to die
there are more cases of tuberculosis
diabetes and AIDS and lives are shorter
in the past few years a wave of suicides
has swept through many of Canada's
Aboriginal community a new study
indicates any way children leave the
world for visits to the hospital for
respiratory infections but though the
alarm has long been sounded on the
health crisis in the north these remote
communities are still struggling with
overwhelming rates of mental health and
lifestyle related disease and often have
been for decades the change in night has
made quite a bit of difference in our
ability to eskom on health the people
have difficulty from the new foods to
which they're exposed
they need help with prevention of spread
of infection they live in very close
quarters and infection spreads rapidly
from one to the other whether it's
tuberculosis or common skin infections
but delivering healthcare in the north
isn't easy it's sparse population has
spread over vast distances in what is
arguably the harshest and most
unforgivable environment on the planet
in many communities only one in four
students ever graduate from high school
let alone obtain the post-secondary
education necessary to work in
healthcare that means most positions are
filled by healthcare workers from the
south who may not be familiar with local
Aboriginal languages or culture turnover
is high and positions remain vacant for
long periods
lavenia curly is an interpreter living
in kicked our track Nunavut a remote
island community off the southeast coast
of Baffin Island like many aboriginals
in Canada's North she struggled with
health issues including addiction abuse
and suicide but like others living in
the Arctic she says getting help isn't
easy the nurses or the social workers
are constantly changing something so
severe as a child sexual abuse you need
someone you can depend on within a small
community there's no such persons she
says this can prevent people like her
from getting the help they desperately
need some aggrenox are in the north and
just for money and not really has any
care of helping that's how a lot of us
you'd see it and you're trying to heal
but you keep repeating it so you angry
with the get angry with the sister and
then you don't want to even bother
trying to get help anymore cuz it's no
use your constant going back a lot of us
wish for someone who will actually be
here or in every in any other community
who will be there and who you can dip
them down good morning Department of
Health and Social Services dr. Geraldine
Osborne is deputy chief medical officer
of Nunavut with public health things
take a long time to establish and get
moving and then you know and if you've
got a whole new staff coming in then
earth staff turnover you're starting at
the beginning quite a lot so it's three
it's pretty frustrating at all levels i
can tell you experts say it will take
time before the number of aboriginals
working in northern healthcare is
representative of the population
but in the places where local healthcare
teams are in place the effect has been
profound they're not only bridging the
gap between Aboriginal culture and the
southern based healthcare system they
stay and have a long-term investment in
their communities this is a birthing
room and this is where lip ring starts I
mean labouring laboring coaching
birthing happens one in and one of our
pets here akan Isaac Houma Luke lives in
preventative nunavik in northern Quebec
and his team leader of the community
midwifery program I feel it's
contributing and hopefully good health
to the babies because we do a lot of
counseling unhealthy habits and alcohol
and smoking and nutritional on family
planning in middle northern regions
expectant mothers are flown to iqaluit
or southern Canada to give birth but
giving birth in a foreign language and
surrounded by strangers often for the
first time can be a difficult experience
for these women the community program
was set up to train local midwives so
expectant mothers could give birth in
their home communities
knowing that i'm working for our
pregnant woman around around the
Hudson's because I want to be good at it
they want to give good service and talk
to them in unity do instead of English
and most rewarding is also delivering
babies Tammy letting them coming to the
world in ineptitude homologue says she
and her colleagues do more than just
support women during birth they're
laying the foundation for the next
generation I want to see healthy babies
being born in our communities because
they are our future they are our future
mayor they are our future teachers
future healthcare workers so in order to
have healthy communities do not drink
alcohol do not smoke cigarettes those
things it's my number one because I want
their brains to be bright and smart and
it's for its to see healthy communities
I niet Korra gak is manager of external
public health relations at nuna votes
Department of Health and Social Services
he's responsible for health promotion
and awareness he says the southern based
system has many strong points but that
the sooner more Aboriginal health
workers and their perspectives can be
incorporated into the system the better
it will be for patients especially
indigenous people plates a lot of faith
and believe that you have the body so of
course no but how you're connected as
individual within the bigger world like
nature for example that isn't always
captured in the current you know health
care system for example you you're here
quite often you know that when people
don't feel when they're depressed were
and then feeling well they're mentally a
day out of the land or even being out
goes a long way and this is something
that the domain society generally don't
you know practicing
akula Vic is a predominantly Inuit
community near the east coast of
Hudson's Bay Daniel a canoe uke says
he's proud to call it home but like in
many other northern regions many
families are still struggling with the
rapid transition from a semi-nomadic
hunting and gathering lifestyle to life
and settled communities and that
motivated canoe you to become a
community liaison wellness worker
responsible for health education and
outreach there is a root that has been
hurt from the past we were raised in the
the camps like a hunting post like
scattered around the coast but once the
government comes and started to put this
in one community that's where the
problem suckers
canoe you calls this the trauma and he
says he's experienced firsthand how it
still affects life today I have lost a
brother on suicide and I have lost a
brother on a and sudden death before i
did my grieving I a turning on
alcoholism when you're grieving inside
when you don't let it out sometimes its
halls in you and you hurting your family
or abusing your family but by sharing
their experiences canoe uke says
wellness workers like him can reach out
to aboriginal Canadians in a way that
someone from the South may not be able
to they've been doing grieving a lot
since over five years now since I start
to work in this in this field by a lot
of help from the outside like not only
in it but First Nation people crees
Mohawks Algonquin as soon as I start to
take it out things went better and
things at home got better it let's drink
when I was growing up my father was one
of the camp leaders and I like when we
go out camping he was one of the leaders
so as a leader he he told us not to cry
but nothing there's nothing wrong with
crying it helps you as soon as start to
grieve a lot of crying started to happen
to me so maybe there was no I shame on
that don't hold your cry because that's
the best tool that's an international
tool
canoe uke says supporting projects that
reconnect Inuit youth to the land is
another key to community health
july osceola Luke is project coordinator
at the Akula big municipal office
hunting is my communication because when
you're out in the line you don't have to
think about a lot of things that what is
going on in town and it's like the many
hunting is like a medication for me too
Lucca see lego is a cool of X recreation
coordinator he's part of a program that
takes local youth hunting he's seen
firsthand how this can change community
health for the better I know you don't
have anything to do they just basically
stay home Anna I would like to keep them
away from drugs and alcohol and make
sure they have something to do because I
up north um when you start doing drugs
it's Canada they're kind of stuck and I
keep doing to keep doing drugs all the
time canoe uke says they're still work
to be done in the north but he believes
that health and well-being in Arctic
communities will continue to improve one
person and one community at a time yuly
day by day night by night knowing
knowing what you're going to be tomorrow
my hope would be better life get rid of
all those bad traumas that that
everybody has been gone through get it
get a better left hobby life that's what
I want to see in 50 years from now
you
you